I'm prepared to be scared didn't even
mean to you're a poet and yet you didn't
realize hello there reject nation I'm
Greg Alba who are you
Amy castles with me today Morgan get in
the spirit of Halloween leo
Nuuk I said we I didn't say I'm gonna
get in the spirit of Halloween I was
reinforcing what you said like what if
I'm saying I've seen oh you need to they
said me too no no like what I said we're
gonna get in stare Holloway you're like
me to read including we're gonna watch
scary ghost videos here come this caught
on camera nooks top 5 channel before we
do that it was my birthday a month ago
and Amy Castle swung by with the
awesomeness of awesome gifts here's the
back side of its just says Happy
Birthday Greg from your friend Amy she
forgot ingrained it she made a real
rejects coaster which we do use only
coaster in the office what would you
call this engraved plaque
yes yep and Amy does these awesome
design this video is brought to you by
created by Cathy
yeah your today's video sponsored
special she's paying us one thousand
dollars to be here today to promote this
and coasters that we are going to sell
for a large profit I have no idea she
didn't get me anything this is like the
most thank you again by the way but if
you want more stuff from Amy like this
or you do like personal engraving I do
custom engraving and I have stuff on my
Etsy anything you think of I can engrave
it see dude you rock my socks and you're
out so I really rock my socks oh yeah
that's how good she is at that
[Music]
let's see the top five ghosts caught on
tape the doorway the Barton mansion in
retro California is considered by many
to be one of the most haunted locations
in the state way back in 2001 two young
men decided to investigate the abandoned
house what they caught on tape remains
one of the most controversial ghost
sightings ever recorded let's see about
that
like that was a real right I gave it
real don't believe oh man are they just
like super committed interest here or
more today 16 years later do men who
recorded the video still clean the
footage that's pretty crazy
if that's their number five years
according to Sean the painting named the
anguished man has a dark history it was
painted by a mentally disturbed man who
committed suicide shortly after
completing it John claims that every
time he gets the painting out of his
attic storage strange things begin to
happen around this house so I'm gonna
send up to the cordon equipment
lady photos hey that was and I'll leave
the light on Danny's voice makes it
scary that's it
okay I really hope nothing pops I
realized I could happen
no I have such strong nipple children I
knew I was gonna fall I knew it was
gonna fall [ __ ] my dough Bowl they've
only posted eight videos to his YouTube
channel he says that between filming's
the painting is kept securely locked
away in his attic why would you why
would you keep that baby away probably
then one of the boys mentions in Arabic
that his phone that had been fully
charged was now about to shut off right
after he says this the cameraman
nonchalantly pans around an abandoned
classroom just then a call to prayer can
be heard from a nearby mosque the camera
catches this strange footage
well wait said that look like they're
half a bottle might have a body walking
towards camera boys couldn't see the
headless apparition with their naked eye
and had no reaction yep
it was only later when watching the
footage back they noticed the chilling
figure in the video I think it looks
like it's dancing CCTV footage from
Jimmy's World grill and Medford sure
England captured some strange activity
in the restaurant on tape a woman did
not tip the ghost tips water oh no
bullsh
that could have been out of frame hmm
somebody just moving other one moved
know how it goes we is that a restaurant
[Music]
now if this scene were being faked with
multiple hoaxers bullying fishing line
there strains it seems like it might
attract a little more attention from the
other diners but in the footage that one
even looks up until the noisy plates and
silverware hit the floor Facundo gomez
is filming himself in what is supposedly
a haunted cemetery in Mexico City I'm
listening there's someone crying from
somewhere in the distance and goes to
investigate
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
crying woman this clip was first posted
to the internet over 12 years ago this
rampant speculation through the years
that the film is a hoax but kundo Gomez
doe claims that his clip is 100% real
and that he captured an actual ghost on
tape I mean it might just feel a regular
person though it does kind of like a
skeleton like it was like a skull of us
but they're so far away there's lighting
at all plays yeah first ones to I felt
like you should have
yeah they got it that was pretty that's
pretty creepy at the lasso but this is
too questionable but that was all more
real than I expected ah this is a lot
spookier than I expected it to be right
from the beginning you know what sold me
on the on the seven-foot tall dude
they're talking about how committed
those guys were how long they ran they
ran a big just cut pretty early on
that's fake they faked it but the fact
they just get bolte maybe minutes of
that long yeah I'm like either they knew
that to make this convincing they would
have to charge as if they were running
for their lives or they really did see a
ghost that scared because that was
pretty creepy
that's a [ __ ] scarecrow with like a
pumpkin on its head yeah a little bit
like a very tall one it looks like when
I used to live with John and how he
looked in the morning so maybe he took a
quick flight the trailer we sold it
you're new to the channel you don't know
who John is join and find out so you get
that joke later on the one with the
painting though first of all that's a
very creepy painting to begin with yes
but the fact that you keep it locked up
why would you keep it I mean do you
believe the footage I don't know you
could easily just like have something
lean oh I don't know I wouldn't be I
wouldn't keep that in my house if that
was real I love how they think it was
like the credibility seems like it's
given when they say like this is the
only video they've ever uploaded then
maybe I feel like the painting ones the
easiest to fake them I'll be it creepy
all these are are creepy videos yes it's
just there's a couple where I go mmm
might not be real like the restaurants
the most believable right because
there's all those people that's like the
least likely to be stay yes well this
could just be VFX but then like what the
people are reacting yeah stuff if it's a
restaurant Jimmy or whatever oh yeah I'm
like Gloucestershire England
yeah the hell are these weird British
non-american names
that Americans apologies it'd be like a
corporation or something they would
speak out and say this isn't real like
someone messed with the footage if it
was right what did they or good business
people hook up or they just like or
creeped out by it and didn't want to
give it any like additional exposure but
it had to be released exactly so they
released it we didn't know the backstory
of that like how was it released what
did they say right I would have been
curious because it wasn't just a dude or
someone with a camera it was security
and release from a restaurant you know
what the restaurant speaks out that was
fake someone took our security we grew
up in an Arab prior to all of that so we
like to have conversations without
looking something up it's true it's true
you children and you're getting falsely
diagnosed with ADHD because you're
addicted to your cell phones so the
torso person headless pert the headless
they look like I have this person see
that could easily be faked up like I
always give these videos credit for at
least pulling off for the immediate
moment of oh that's that's crazy I get
creeped out I'm not like only arms
crossed fake because I always give it
credit even if it is fake yeah sure yeah
I want them to be real kind of wish
right
I like lean into it and maybe it's the
actor in me that's just like oh well how
would I feel if I was there and that'll
happen and I'm sitting here in this
chair like freaking out so don't get me
any closer to those paranormal
experience I know how you feel a me
Castle well but the graveyard lady that
could just be a real person right it
could be crying at the graveyard he went
to a haunted cemetery potentially
filming that filming it for this he's by
himself
Oh likely story if someone is going with
the intention to hopefully capture
something with night vision sure this
could easily be doctored
there's a lady crying over you know a
lost one that's a raper that's not hard
to fathom the face look weird it just
kind of looked like a skull to me but
he's far away in its night vision but
it's also twelve years ago that is the
other thing too the quality projection
or maybe with his age
I'd leave in Mexico this was before that
were free Instagram with a pre that
Paris smelter that you just swipe over
and make yourself look a little better
yeah pretty face app days I get that
face out this video is also sponsored by
facing I don't know which ones are real
and which ones are fake the only one I
actually believe is the Jimmy restaurant
one because there's just too much
everything else everything else I'm
skeptical I don't believe the painting I
think you could easily fake yes is too
easy to fit the first one it creeped me
out so much
yeah you know what even if it is not I'm
not a hundred percent sold but I'll give
it to them I'll vote yeah it's real yes
torso person now I don't believe that in
the last one I just think the guy got a
woman on camera yeah and that woman is
scary to me it wasn't it wasn't this
should have been scary either way new
top fives thanks for putting this
together nukes top 5 that's what it's
called hey guys you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bells tell us in the comments any ghost
encounters you
yeah be in your comments reading all of
those that's a ute that's right talk
good things about Amy she'll talk good
things about you back Amy what should I
plug for you other than castle builds
castles I remembered CBC I see me rock
that's the one follow her on social
media I'd like to end this video with a
page today shots a man named Chris wama
Chris is a management pleasure our
patreon page we started talking quite a
bit in the beginning and then all the
sudden he sort of fell off the map
haven't really heard from him he still
stays pledged you know where I'm going
with this Chris he's a ghost who has
decided for his afterlife experience to
pledge to the real rejects patreon page
can you imagine if a dead person's
enjoying this like Chris wham-o soul
feel good feel alive makes you feel
alive so if you feel like you're rotting
internal go pledge to the real rejects
patreon page in memory of Chris message
me back